my dad hit me once and once in my life
only and I called my mom a oh boy
and yeah she told my dad so my dad comes
to the house one day he goes come on
we'll go to the bar we'll get a beer he
goes you're a man now and I said no I'm
not I'm 16 and he was like no you're a
man you called your mother a
that's what men do right and I said no
what do you mean he goes come get a beer
with me you're a man you're calling
women a you can't have a beer
you're scared to drink a beer but you
call your mother a I don't get it
and then bang punched me like full like
in my chin I don't know that he followed
through but punched me that I like fell
back into the wall and then immediately
gives me like a fatherly Like Loving hug
and he was like whispering in my ear was
like I'm sorry I love you I love you so
much I had to do that don't ever make me
do that again but if you ever call your
mother a again I'm going to hit
you every single time and and then he
goes so go up there and apologize to her
and we'll go get pizza